a data class in Python is a class
focused solely on holding data values
without the need for additional methods
while they assemble regular classes they
serve the purpose of efficiently storing
information for communication between
different parts of program or system
however repeatedly writing the init
method can generate incredible work and
potential errors when creating classes
to work only as a data containers
Python's data classes module introduced
in version 3.7 offers a simplified
approach to creating such courses
without the necessity of manually
writing the methods hi everyone my name
is mik and in this video we will explore
utilizing the data classes module
showcasing how it is streamlines the
creation of new classes with this module
not only does it automatically include
the init method but it also provides
several other pre-implemented methods
reducing the need for manual
implementations all of these can be
achieved with just a few lines of code
overall python is your gateway to data
science Mastery if you want to become a
data scientist with our courses from
prestigious University it's just a piece
of cake supercharge your data science
career with a post-graduate degree in
data science from P University and IBM
in collaboration with simply learn gain
ml python T generative ai explainable ai
chat gity and more expertise benefit
from master classes by PD faculty and
IBM expert elevate your skills now after
completing the course simply Lear
Learners have made successful career
transition boosted career growth and got
salary hikes with this course delve into
essential topics like python R ml data
visualization generative ai explainable
ai chat GPT and many more using an
Interactive Learning approach with live
session led by global expert elevate
your data skills with us the course link
is in the description box and the pin
comment so take action upskill and get
ahead so without any further Ado let's
get started so welcome to this Dem part
of data classes so data classes are
super beneficial over here it will
really reduce your whole lot of time
with respect to coding and when you
probably specifying working object
oriented programming with respect to
creating classes with respect to
creating variables and with respect to
defining various and build function with
this present inside the classes so if
you really interested and want to really
save time please make sure that it will
be an amazing tutorial to go ahead with
so I'm just going to show you a lot of
example I hope everyone knows about the
classes objectoriented Concepts right
inheritance and all now the previous way
of how we used to use and now with the
help of this data classes accurat or
concept over here everything is going to
get simplified so let's go ahead without
wasting any time so so first here I will
write from data
classes
import
data
class make sure the library is installed
in your system or you can install like
PP install data class okay so
data
class
I'm making one Clause as a
person okay so first I will write name
St Str this is a string okay then H be
integer then
profession okay then again
string right so here I will write
person person one equals
to uh I will write here
person this
my comma my
age then
profession python
developer right so as soon as I will
print this person one what happened see
I will run
it see the whole person name age and
profession is here
right so as soon as we call this class
person here so what is happening the
data class decorator automatically
generate the following methods for you
like first is init so in it initialize
the object and assigns the provided
value to the attributes then the rapper
provides a string representation of the
object then EQ this implements equality
comparision between two objects of the
class on there right
so everything is happening internally
you don't have to Define externally
anything
okay so okay so next uh how you can
change the particular you know the given
value so I will write here
from from data classes import data
class okay then uh okay I will write it
the class then
class uh
person
right then I will write
name okay s
Str then
RO
number okay then
integer
then
profession okay or I can write here
school
name okay so I can give a string
directly
okay so I will write here school name St
Str equals
to equals to so school name same
John
okay
now yes I will write here
person St
John person
two to
person person
right then Z number will be
44 that's
it then
print person
two okay invalid syntax fine we can't
give a space right we can use
underscore school name
right so now what you can do for the
changing so you can simply write here
person to dot
profession oh sorry not profession
school
name okay then equals to you can write
the different name
s or I write
Oxford University
Okay then if I will write
print person to that see you can change
the name okay so the unit that also can
be actually handled by the data classes
right so there is one con More Concept
of this Frozen
classes okay so uh which is known as the
immutable classes so how you can create
the immutable classes first I will write
here
immutable
classes so I will write here
data
class so here Frozen is the word
okay Frozen is uh I'm setting it
true then I will write
class
Square okay then X = to
and yals to and sorry not equals
to okay so I will write here
square equals
to square the function name data class
name then 3 comma 4 okay so print
square right so it will print x = 3 y =
4 right what if you want to change the
value of x okay so I will write here
Square dot
x equals to
32 so you know cannot assign to field X
so this will this is the error so it is
happening because of this Frozen so what
Frozen do Frozen set is just an
immutable version of a python set object
so while elements of a set can be
modified at any time then element of
Frozen set remain the same after the
creation so due to this Frozen sets can
be used as a key dictionary like we used
to do in SQL SQL or as the elements of
another set right so this is how you can
use data class you can use data class
for The Inheritance you can use data
class for the storing variables and for
many other things right so so with this
said we have come to end of this video I
hope you like this video if you have any
queries please comment down below our
team of expert will help you as soon as
possible thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here